With a runtime that exceeds the four-hour mark,
Zack Snyder's Justice League differs wildly from
the 2017 theatrical version of Justice League,
which was comprised heavily of footage and scenes
that were either reshot, added, or rewritten by
Avengers director Joss Whedon. The 2017 cut was
very different from what Snyder had originally
intended the film to be, and as a result,
many fans have taken to regarding the Snyder Cut
as the one and only "real" version of the film.
Of course, DC fans weren't the only ones happy to
see the release of Zack Snyder's Justice League.
The fan campaign that ultimately led
to the completion of the Snyder Cut was
boosted over the years by comments
from several Justice League stars
who expressed their desire to see the
original version of the film released.
Snyder himself also appears to be visibly relieved
and grateful to have gotten the chance to return
to the project — even if it also marks the
end of his time in the DCEU once and for all.
It looks like it's not just DC
fans or members of the film's
creative team who were excited to
see the updated, four hour marathon.
"We have to stand together."
Jeffrey Dean Morgan shared his reaction
to the film on Twitter this past weekend,
with the Walking Dead actor adding to the growing
pile of online praise for the film by tweeting,
"HELL YES. #snydercut congratulations
my friend. You did us proud."
Despite having no role in the film
itself, Morgan was one of several
notable celebrities who tweeted about it last
week. Avengers: Endgame directors Anthony and
Joe Russo also publicly tweeted their excitement
and support for the film ahead of its premiere.
Of course, Morgan himself does have some
connections to the DC Universe, even if he has no
role in the actual film. The actor has a history
with Snyder, having appeared as The Comedian in
Snyder's 2009 film adaptation of Watchmen. Morgan
also had a small role as Thomas Wayne — the late
father of Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne — in 2016's
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice. Right now,
the actor stars as Negan on AMC's The Walking
Dead and isn't currently slated to appear in any
of Snyder's upcoming films, but it's clear that he
still feels a strong connection to the filmmaker.
Morgan's reaction also comes at the
same time that many fans are still
calling for his presence in the DCEU to be
revived in a future DC comics adaptation.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan's role in Batman v
Superman: Dawn of Justice was, admittedly,
brief. The actor only appeared as Thomas Wayne
in one of the film's opening flashback scenes,
and he hasn't been seen again in any other DCEU
film. But that hasn't stopped DC comics fans from
publicly calling for Morgan to be brought
back as Thomas Wayne in a solo Flash film.
Specifically, DC fans have been open about their
desire to see Morgan's take on Thomas Wayne return
in a possible adaptation of the Flashpoint
storyline from the comics, which saw The Flash
arrive in an alternate reality where Thomas Wayne
became Batman after watching his son, Bruce, die.
Unfortunately, despite the overwhelming
fan support for Morgan's DCEU return,
it seems unlikely that the actor will be
reprising his role as Thomas Wayne anytime soon.
Instead, Michael Keaton is currently
set to return as Batman in director
Andy Muschietti's Flash movie, while Morgan's
time in the DCEU appears to be up. At least,
that's what the actor told Comicbook.com last
year in response to Keaton's return, saying,
"Michael Keaton swooped in and took my gig. Naw,
I think that's super cool. Ever since Zack
Snyder walked away, my whole kind of bit in
that world has walked away with him. However,
there's always a chat going on. So, we'll see!"
In other words, it looks like Jeffrey
Dean Morgan's screen time in the DCEU
may end up being confined to just a few
moments. However, it's clear that he's
not letting that stop him from continuing
to show support for Zack Snyder's work.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the DC
Extended Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.